it's me once again up in this
[ __ ]
um
and um i like to speak about
something that's that's that's vital man
to to to my success man even today
you know i'm coming on four years
of being out of prison
um
not off the crack
you know
not not not from from from being um
subjected to to the trials and
tribulations man
that that that me wanting to do every
[ __ ] thing on my own
you know and i'm wanting to think and
and do what i feel is best for me man
has put me in some real bad situations
man fortunate i haven't had to go back
to [ __ ] rehab i have to have to
venture back to prison i have been
having i didn't have to experience uh
homelessness again
but i'm not i'm not off the
[ __ ] woods
i'm not free i haven't been set free
from the bonus of this [ __ ]
what i think at how i feel
about me
and the people i surround myself with
you know i always thought man no matter
what i would be able to do it on my own
if i can just muster up the courage and
stand on my own two [ __ ] feet
then i can overcome anything but i was
wrong dead [ __ ] wrong
especially with that crack
oh i can do it
i know i can i'm bigger and better than
crack that was a [ __ ] lie
and the coldest part about it man what
woke me up to that reality was my mental
health [ __ ] issues that's why i
got to check up from the neck up
i don't want to take no medication
i don't want to be different
i just want to be me
i just want to be a natural born human
being man going through
life struggling fumbling rumbling
whatever man but at least i can just
muster just do it on my own navigating
and searching and exploring and find
what works and what don't work
and with mental illness man i learned
man that i couldn't i couldn't do it on
my own i didn't have i didn't have the
power to fight that because i was
fighting me
i'd never been quite right
never thought quite right never feel
quite right how the [ __ ] am i gonna be
whole
if i don't even start off in that in
that area where i'm complete but i'm
gonna fight something that's
dysfunctional that's disrupted
wasn't no smooth selling from the
beginning to the end
it's always been turbulence on the way
in my life there's been a heist there's
been a laws the ends the officer ends
betweens
lost in a [ __ ] source
for years
because i thought i could do it by
myself oh i couldn't do it alone
i was created by myself and when i don't
believe this [ __ ] by myself
then i got to fight the good fight by
myself and i was completely wrong
and to make matters worse
or should i say
to add
insult to injury
i was always surrounded by the wrong
people
who fed me the wrong information who
gave me the wrong information who who
thought process was on some [ __ ] on
some negative stuff
and even though that wasn't me because i
was raised different i was raised i was
raised by my mom single parent all that
[ __ ] the household but she gave me
some morals and she gave me some values
you know so when she was taught as a
young girl as a woman going into
womanhood
you know she was able to give me the
best that she had to give advice from
per se her mom giving her and her father
giving her you know my grandfather was
the first black police chief in ohio see
he was on a job 35 years never had to
shoot somebody never
i think he had one one incident we shot
somebody in the leg and hated to do that
you know my uncle marines
you know
my grandfather was the first black
police chief
i speak voting so you can imagine the
kind of information that she was given
growing up and she imparted it to me
so even though i played dumb
in actuality i wasn't
when it came to right from wrong
you know i knew better i just chose not
to do better that's on me i can't blame
a [ __ ] for me not putting forth
the effort to be the best that i can to
show up each and every day to be a part
of society contribute to society not
even [ __ ] about society because i didn't
care about me
so evidently the people around me that i
surrounded myself they felt the same way
about themselves
then i'm wondering why i'm sinking in
this [ __ ] quick quicksand
slowly but surely they can't none of
them help get me out
i look around we all up in that
[ __ ] together all of us is in
that that part lost in the sauce all
lovers so you got me up in that
[ __ ] got him got cheryl got pete
got a little ray ray and little round
round and we all up in there
it's like the crabs in a barrel
as soon as you wanna try to climb up
there's a [ __ ] pulling them back
down
story of my life
ain't that some [ __ ]
forgive me
forgive me
it's imperative man
that i strive to continue man to put one
foot in front of the other
that i don't give up the fight for
what's right
and that i always
embrace and welcome anything good
in my life good fortune good advice good
words of wisdom good people good food
anything man that helps to build me and
bring up the best of me
[ __ ] i'm all for it i'm gung-ho
i care
about family
love my family to death all my
[ __ ] family
but i don't have no close relationship
with them
i don't have no connection
i'm not connected
but they good folk god damn it
love my sister to death good woman been
through some [ __ ] like we all have but
we ain't connected like we used to when
i was growing up
prison disconnected that
my brother we've never been close
he put forth an effort
she just ain't
working the only reason why my me and my
mama's still close is because when i was
in prison all those [ __ ] times
she wrote me letters and kept me abreast
of what was going on outside on the
streets of my family
i saw that connection last with us
that's how i was able to build upon a
relationship with her
you know she good folk
always said my back and always will
nephews two of them love them to death
but we're not close once putting forth
an effort i give them that
god bless them bless this [ __ ]
soul for reaching out to me
this is putting forth an effort
i had a uh i had fear with the friends
before i went to prison this last time
around
and um i was going from 2011 to 2017. i
ain't seen one of the [ __ ]
since i've been home i've been home
almost four years
i've encountered some haters
some naysayers
but no fair weather friends
i have been fortunate
to meet some people who changed my life
and i could never go back to the man
that i was
started in prison by one man having a
relationship with him building
relationship be a trust took three years
to break those [ __ ] walls down
that i have built up
and since i've been home
i have an all-star supporting cavs man
you know um
with the mental health you know i have
the the people without piece of program
that they keep me right right on the
street and they were to keep me on point
uh my immediate family my mama
uh outside my family i have uh people
like uh
like the the producer of this channel
got my bad gave me this platform to
speak from you know
and uh my forever be grateful for the
opportunity
to be on soft white underbelly and in
sharing and giving you the best that i
got all that i've got to give
first time i have to try some [ __ ] like
this with my life and i love it cause
i'm not taken from i'm not hurting
nobody today
trying to even i'm trying
i'm trying to clean my [ __ ]
slate
trying to even up the score from being
bad all those years to being good and
trying to balance some [ __ ] out
tired of being behind the eight ball
trying to catch up
trying to learn something or do
something she did 20 30 years ago
tired of that
you know i'm finally getting a break i'm
getting breaks in life today i'm getting
cut some slack
here and there
and men don't i need it
yes lord i need it
more than most folks
you know my thing is this
i've i've known some people i have some
people on my life that i've known for a
few years
since i've been home from prison
and
they have been nothing
it you know it's it's it's been
it's been a strain on me to maintain and
to do whatever to be the best that i can
be while having these people in my life
while having this connection you know i
have some connections with some people
doing the cover 19.
uh
you know i just when coping 19 hit um
the gyms closed so i was i went to
depression and all that [ __ ] and
malnutrition i wasn't eating sleeping
drinking water nothing
and um the crater looked up for me
introduced me to this man named doug i
worked for him for nine months to learn
how to do carp i learned how to how to
uh uh uh uh paint i learned how to
refurbish floors and what this brother
named jerome i learned how to lay
concrete in in uh and paint also but do
the details in a painting
and um
now even though our relationships didn't
last long that connection was there you
know it was there i had that connection
so what happened was aside from learning
how to how to work or how to how to
learn a new craft
you know i was able to to to get the
information that they would share with
me while we were working we i see i was
in a work relationship with these being
with these men but outside of the work
relationship or doing a work
relationship it was the information that
was given to me
that's what sustained me that's what got
me through the cover 19 and that's what
kept me from going back to the [ __ ]
the the 101s the conversation
information sharing their experience
with me sharing what it was like for
them showing when they were young and
all that [ __ ] you know it it it it
saved the day for me until the gyms
opened back up
i'm back in the [ __ ] gym
been there for about three months hip
hip hooray
love being up in that [ __ ] hole
can't blame me it's why excel
you know
i don't
i've never had friends
i've never had many friends even today
you can tell you can i can count them on
one hand
include my mama
i used to think it was a damn shame
you know i used to think less than like
man why
why am i going through life
being an isolator being being a loner
when i was created to have relationships
with people
i was created to be surrounded by people
that nurture and learn and grow and all
that [ __ ]
you know but the cool thing about it is
but everybody ain't on the same page and
everybody you know on the same track no
matter who the [ __ ] you surround
yourself with
they might say to your friends they may
say they're cool with you and they want
the best for you
you know but i never forget somebody
said to me once man if a [ __ ]
show you something man take them at
their work that that's who they are the
first time they it's like the first
impression
they might say oh i apologize for
hurting you or i apologize for doing
this to doing that
you know
you say okay i'll give you another
chance but knowing
knowing in the gut of your [ __ ]
stomach
that something's going to happen later
on down the road it's going to be some
it's going to be some [ __ ] in the
game
it might not come in the same form but
it and it won't come in the same
packaging but it's going to be some
[ __ ] nonetheless you know and for
some people you there's a lot that you
have to sift through and for some
there's very little
because most of them is putting the
cards on the table the ones that are
really there for you they'll let you
know up front man i don't want nothing
from you there's no interior motors you
know
and there's no streets attached to this
[ __ ] work relationship person
relationship friendship there's no
strings attached you ain't got to do a
[ __ ] thing
you don't you ain't gonna owe me nothing
then those are the ones you don't have
to sift through a lot of the [ __ ]
cause they're already coming correct
they're already coming clean they're
already putting the cards on the table
so you can see it for what it is and
it's your choice to deal with them or
not
that's where i get on the day [ __ ] i
ain't got nothing to hide what the [ __ ]
i just shared everything
you know that was important to me
you know
i'm looking for friends i'm looking for
some real relationships i'm looking for
some real personal relationships today
i need all the help i can get but i need
the right hill
i need a real [ __ ] friend not
no fair weather friend that's somebody
that's got some arterial motors
want to play a [ __ ] out of
pocket or stab me in a [ __ ]
back
if i hurt his or her feelings then put
you know put all my [ __ ] up
put all my lingerie out there you know
for the world
i don't need people like that in my life
man if you say you're my [ __ ]
friend stand on that you ain't got to
prove it to me
just stand on that truth
i'm not asking you to prove nothing to
me
you ain't got to do nothing
got to take care of me loan me money
none of that i just want you to be real
with me
help me along
as i try to help others
we all need each other
god damn
it ain't easy
i'm so used to being by myself and being
alone this [ __ ] is killing me
i need love
i need to be in a healthy loving
relationship with any and everybody that
i come in contact with if you with it
if not to stay the [ __ ] away from me
keep it moving
please i don't need that i don't need
the drama
i need the healing part of relationships
friendships
i've been looking for love in all the
wrong places for about 30 [ __ ]
years now i'm ready to just settle down
you know any takers
women only i love women
sorry fellas
don't get down like that
just something i went through something
i did
for the love that cracked [ __ ]
cocaine
cat's been off the bed i got a
[ __ ] thing to hide ain't no
shame in my game it is what it is been
there done that had my five minutes of
fame now it's time to move on to a new
life to a new beginning
and that's where i'm at
so new people
who's looking for something different
than that old [ __ ] they've been
dealing with
with people places and things here i am
taking full responsibility
for me and you being responsible to me
and you
practicing integrity for me and you
love intolerance for me and you
patience and guidance for you and me
and unconditional love for you and me
because i can't get it unless i give it
any takers
my life is on the line
and if i mess up and get in trouble i
can get 25 to life
if i [ __ ] around with that crack i can
lose my place and be homeless man like
like that
don't take my medication like if i take
my medication and surround myself with
the people like i'm supposed to
keep that routine going on
i'm liable to lose my [ __ ] mind
it just ain't worth it and i just can't
afford to take that chance
so i do everything in my powers to make
sure that i'm i'm cool with my
medication that i'm cool with the
doctors and the psychiatrists and all
that kind of stuff my my uh my old
patient uh uh supporting crew my members
cast whatever [ __ ] you want to call it
you know
and um
i remember
i read a book in prison called rise of
the vulcans
and it was uh president bush cabinet
members and they talked about all of
them individually there was 12 of them
12 members from colon power to rice and
the rest of them
and it was interesting the part that
they played to his success and
presidency even though he didn't do too
good when he was in office president
bush but the support and cash
if it wasn't for them
it would have man
and i see how important it was for the
cabinet members to have his back man he
picked the right people for the right
jobs because they played their
[ __ ] positions to the best to
the team
and uh
that's why i have mine today my
outpatient pro my outpatient uh uh
members man
you know they played their [ __ ]
positions to the t man they got me and i
know that
i don't have to worry about them i don't
have to bother about veering left or
veering right because they'll know
they're going to keep me on the straight
narrow
when i get hurt by somebody that i
consider a friend
even an associate i'll give him a chance
and i'll give him another chance and
another chance and another chance and
another [ __ ] chance because
that was done to me
when i was out there battling that crap
and i was running around man like a
chicken with my head cut off
i think about my mama how many
opportunities she gave me over and over
again
strangers
that took a chance on
me so i got to give it back but god damn
there's a time when enough is enough
i can't swim and have you on my back too
you got to swim you got to help yourself
swim sometimes too i can carry your hair
some of the way
but you ca i can't swim with you on my
on my back all the way to shore
i'm going to drink i'm going to get
terror fast and i'm going i'm going to
drown and we're both going to die
i need your help not no life preserver
not no [ __ ] life vote not no
helicopter none of that
all i need to know
is that
if you ask me for something and i give
it and i ask in return
i shouldn't be denied
i shouldn't hear i can't
i would if i could i don't i don't need
that
if i actually [ __ ] for anything
lo and behold you can best believe if
they ask me i'll say yes whatever it is
if i'm willing to ask you for something
i got to be able to give it in return
i got to think that all before even ask
you a question pertinent like that i
have to be
i have to know that well if this person
asked me some [ __ ] like that would i be
would it be a yes or maybe or no you
know that goes through my mind
you know because it's important
you know
so i've got to be able to give
just as much as i can take when it comes
to being a relationship
you know i have friendships today that i
cherish
that will trade for nothing in the world
you know
i'm i'm looking
love is on the horizon
my spirit is yearning
for the female companion man for for my
for my compliment or somebody to
compliment me to enhance
to help
to guide
you know i can leave
i said we can do that side by side
you know
and if you're in a position that you can
help you show me the way [ __ ] i'll i'll
follow you i'll follow your lead
sugar ain't no shame in the game
you're heading in the right direction or
you or your or your feet are playing on
selling
uh selling foundation i'm going to be
right there with you
and if my [ __ ] is still kind of shaky
then you share with me like iron
sharpener so we'll be standing on the
same kind of solid foundation
headed in the same direction same
mindset
going with the flow with the stream of
life
i never realized how important it was to
have the
the
the uh positive
thinking people
in my corner as a supporting cavs man
you know because i've never really
considered the difference that it would
make man in in the success or the
failure you know in my life man
i still stay by myself i still take
responsibility i'm still responsible
but at times man
i need the positive input i need the
positive information still man because
my mind still played tricks on me with
that negative stuff with the past and
all that [ __ ] so
i need some update information i need
some new information i need some new
people in my life who's willing to help
assist me along the way by the
information that they provide for me man
so i have to keep up with my head
against that wall i bump my head against
the wall so much you don't even hurt no
more
you know
you can't even see the lump
but you can see all these cars you can't
even see the scars but they're on the
inside you know for my past mistakes and
all that [ __ ] but the bottom line is
man
people save the day
my creator saves the day
the right information saves the day
you know but when it's at the end of the
day when it's all said and done i got to
be able to save the [ __ ] day
too
because when all said and done i still
have to step up to the plate
and try my turn at bat and who knows i
just might be able to hit it off the
park one more time
amen to that thank you
you